لا شك ان موازين القوه في الحرب
الاوكرانيه لم تبقى على حالها كما كان
عليه الحلق عند بدايه الحرب الجيش الروسي
بات اليوم يواجه جيشا اوكرانيا معززا
باسلحه غربيه متطوره ومتنوعه لكن السؤال
المطروح الان كيف يمكن ان تنتقل كيف من
مرحله الدفاع الى مرحله البحث عن الانتصار
في الحرب سؤال طرحته مجله فورين فارس
الامريكيه التي حاولت تلخيص العوامل التي
قد تساعد اوكرانيا على حسم الحرب لصالحها
تقول المجله ان اهم خطوه يمكن ان يتخذها
حلفاؤه اوكرانيا هي تزويدها بالاسلحه التي
ستسمح لقوتها بشن هجمات على القوات
الروسيه واشاره المجله الى حاجه اوكرانيا
لمنظومات صواريخ طويله المدى مثل منظومه
الامريكيه البالغ مدى صواريخها 300 كلم
كما سيحتاج الجيش اوكراني الى قدرات جويه
هجوميه اقوى اقوى بكثير بما في ذلك طائرات
مقاتله واخرى بدون طيار وشددت المجله على
ضروره مواصله تشديد العقوبات على موسكو
بشكل كبير ومحاوله تصنيف الاتحاد الروسي
كدوله راعيه للارهاب كما اكدت المجله على
ان مواصله خفض سقف اسعار صادرات النفط
الروسيه سيضعف روسيا بشكل كبير